vamos a calcular el resultado de tres
entre 0.75 y te voy a dar una pequeña
pista antes de que te diga que pausa es
el vídeo vamos a representar tres
enteros aquí y qué te parece si vemos
estos tres enteros estas tres unidades
en términos de centésimos bueno para eso
podemos expresar a cada uno de ellos
como centésimos y pensar en cuántos
grupos de setenta y cinco centésimos
podemos dividir tres enteros en cuántos
grupos iguales de setenta y cinco
centésimos podemos dividir estos tres
enteros y para ayudarte un poco más aquí
tenemos de manera visual la división de
tres en grupos iguales de setenta y
cinco centésimos
así que pausa el vídeo y utiliza esta
gran pista visual para resolver tres
dividido por 75 centésimas
bien ahora vamos a hacerlo juntos bueno
como dije empezamos con tres unidades o
tres enteros como lo quieras ver y
puedes realizar la división entre
setenta y cinco centésimos diciendo
cuántos grupos iguales de setenta y
cinco centésimos pueden dividir estos
tres enteros bueno si divido estos tres
enteros en términos de centésimos y
pensamos en la forma que tiene este
código de color puedes ver que nos da
cuatro grupos iguales de setenta y cinco
centésimos incluso podemos contarlos
tenemos 10 20 30 40 50 60 70 y después
cinco centésimos más así que aquí
tenemos un grupo de setenta y cinco
centésimos después en verde tenemos otro
grupo de setenta y cinco centésimos
tenemos diez
30 40 50 60 70 y después 75 entonces
este es nuestro segundo grupo el otro
era nuestro primer grupo ok
déjame escribirlo y después tenemos
nuestro tercer grupo son grupos iguales
de setenta y cinco centésimos y por
último nuestro cuarto grupo igual de
setenta y cinco centésimos en color
verde así que cuantos grupos iguales de
setenta y cinco centésimos tengo en tres
enteros
bueno claramente la respuesta es 4